this episode is brought to you by
upstart what's up guys Jared here unless
you're brand new to the internet you've
probably encountered some good
old-fashioned online rage like grief at
a Funeral
happiness at a pizza party or
humiliation at a bar mitzva rage is an
emotion that seems to innately belong on
the internet now I'm definitely not an
angry dude but I've succumbed to my
small share of internet rage in the dark
days following the game of Thrones
finale
I may have ranted over gchat to anyone
who would listen I may have even come
this close to signing a toothless
Internet petition demanding it be remade
with better writers in short I praised a
little bit and what did I get out of it
not much it didn't make me feel better
or more empowered I wouldn't say it was
a net benefit for my life but who does
benefit when we get pissed off on the
Internet
let's investigate welcome to this
wisecrack edition on internet rage but
before we get to it I want to give a
shout out to our sponsors over at
upstart upstart is the leading
marketplace for providing personal loans
if you have a history of credit card
debt if you have credit card debt you
know how hard it is to get your head
above water especially if your credit
score isn't great upstart rewards you
based on your job and education history
in the form of a smarter interest rate
they believe that you are more than just
your credit humbler it's simple fast and
easy to check your rate without
affecting your credit score when your
loan is approved and accepted most
people can receive funds the next day
over 300,000 people have used up start
to pay off their credit cards student
loans on their weddings and make other
large purchases so free yourself from
the burden of high interest debt by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with up start-up start
is ranked number one in their category
out of 300 other businesses on
Trustpilot
go to up Starcom slash wisecrack to find
out how low your up start rate is it
takes a few minutes and it won't affect
your credit and now back to the show of
course rage on the internet runs the
gamut it's generally political but not
always it's sometimes justified and
oftentimes not sometimes some celebrity
has said something so blood-boiling need
to watch 5 suggested videos about why
this person is human trash sometimes
someone gave
baby teeth now we have a theory about
how rage functions in the online
ecosystem and like most delightful and
or vaguely upsetting things in the world
it's tied up in money specifically we're
looking to philosopher Peter slaughter
dykes book rage and time a psycho
political investigation which constructs
the history of rage from ancient Greece
to present-day
slaughter tyke starts by arguing that
rages at its core and experience that D
numbs a person a scalding hot coffee mug
for the soul in this way anger is a
fundamentally energizing force imbuing
you with the vigor necessary to seize
control of your own life like many of
our emotions though we want our rage to
be recognized or legitimized by someone
or something more powerful than
ourselves
rage in this sense is an important
aspect of psycho politics because it is
a demand to be seen slaughtered Icke
argues rage becomes the momentum of a
movement into the future which one can
understand as the raw material for
historical change rage starts Wars
overthrows governments and ends unhappy
marriages rage has manifested
differently at various points in human
history for the ancient Greeks that
their gods sanctioned their rage by
granting them luck in battle but near
the end of ancient history something
shifted collective rage started being
seen as a valuable resource for social
manipulation in which collective fits of
anger were planned into existence by
powerful dudes with highly specific
motives here's where it's helpful to
start thinking of rage through an
economic lens slaughter dyke contends
that rage should be understood as an
economic resource of which every person
has a finite amount that they can spend
in any number of ways
of course since basically the
development of currency savvy people
have opted not to keep their
life-savings under the mattress instead
wisely investing in in banks similarly
rage works like an investable monetary
resource that you can put in a rage bank
the first rage bank slaughter Dyke
argues was developed by the Catholic
Church we're in regular folks were asked
to invest their anger through bombastic
sermons that threaten them with eternal
damnation they accordingly invested all
their rage into the bank of a vengeful
God who would come
back on the apocalypse and lash out at
all the non-believers basically rather
than getting personal revenge on people
who didn't share their religious views
believers were assured by the church
that like a trusty wingman with a Sikh
uppercuts God would take care of it for
them just as a regular bank will hold
your money for you until you need it so
too would the Catholic Church hold your
rage until the apocalypse in this way
rage changed the course of history by
creating an effective way for a power
structure the church to control the
masses slaughter Dyke finds another
palpable manifestation of economic rage
that developed in the late 19th century
with the rise of communism the Communist
Party tapped into the pre-existing
anxiety resentment and indeed rage of
the dispossessed poor telling him that
the source of all their woes lay in the
corrupt brunch loving booze huazi the
Communist Party very deliberately
developed systems mekka Nations and
operations to produce rage amongst the
lower-class harness it and funnel it
into the revolution through propaganda
manifestos Collective organizing and
lots and lots of red paraphernalia the
Communist Party amassed the rage of its
followers and invested it telling them
to funnel all their rage into hating on
and overthrowing the wealthy and
especially the monarchy in this way
slaughter dykes seized communist leaders
like Lenin and Mao as the very first
rage entrepreneurs finding savvy ways to
invest the rage of the masses into a
cause they could all get behind and one
which would majorly pay off for those in
charge here we see the way rage
literally changed the course of history
by triggering revolution for better or
worse in all of the cases above rages
have somewhere to live within a culture
but slaughter dyke argues in
contemporary society there's nowhere to
put it in the past communities served as
repositories for anger but nowadays
instead of expressing our rage at the
town market or local square dancing barn
party or hyper individualistic sitting
at home with our air pods in mumbling a
brilliant too late takedown of that guy
who cut you in line at Chipotle the
point is solidarity between communities
religions and class has faded
cick went li we as a society have failed
to give our collective rage a proper
home now remember the crucial parts of
satisfying cathartic rage is recognition
by something higher than ourselves as
the world gets hyper connected and
individualistic meaningful recognition
becomes an increasingly scarce resource
as a result a lot more of us feel
ignored or unimportant and alongside
that sense our rage yielding little
recognition creating a massive group of
people who feel exploited and ignored by
those in power so what happens to rage
when we a have no collective place to
store it and be are left to experience
it on our own without any plan target
for it or any validation from above I'll
give you a hint what two angry moms
angry Star Wars fans angry neo-nazis
angry vegans angry Beyonce lovers angry
ferret owners and angry Christmas fans
all have in common they all choose to
rage on the Internet the vacuum created
by lack of community is being filled by
the internet allotting rage - causes
ranging from gamergate to petitions
hating on the game of thrones writers
unsurprisingly studies have shown that
high arousal emotions whether positive
like odd how this nebula looks like it's
hosting a rave for unicorns or negative
like anger at the Ghostbusters remake
for ruining your childhood are far more
likely to go viral than low arousing
emotions like sadness a point
demonstrated by a viral content bill up
worthy in this graphic rage in short is
clicking a brief scan of top headlines
over the past few years indicates an
almost rabid level of anger people are
being fed when they check their news
feed from Obama saluting the Marines
while scandalously holding his latte to
the new Peter Rabbit making light of
food allergies there's no shortage of
things to be angry about the problem is
in the absence of a rage bank there's
nowhere for us to store our anger just
as you can view the Catholic Church as a
rage bank and the Communist Party as a
rage entrepreneur we think it's helpful
to contextualize each social media
platform as a sort of rage stock
exchange or rages bot sold and
prospected here let's go back to
slaughter dykes explanation
how any kind of rage economy is formed
in that it is planned by its agents
according to entrepreneurial criteria
and controlled by its managers with
long-term oversight in the case of
YouTube the agents of this stock market
are the platform owners aka Google
bigwigs trying to maximize profit with
the help of algorithms that will
maximize view time this often means
recommending videos that you will find
enraging because rage equals engagement
individual youtubers can be seen like
the leaders of the Communist Party as
rage entrepreneurs directing users rage
laser-like towards specific topics that
will keep them watching however unlike
the Communist revolution there is
usually not an identifiable project for
people to use their rage to actualize
the only goal on behalf of the
entrepreneurs is self-interest they're
trying to generate YouTube views amass
patreon subscriptions and sometimes sell
apocalypse gift bags the rage being
stirred up is inherently
self-perpetuating and fruitless it's in
the platform's interest to keep you
raging so you keep consuming more videos
what's more all this youtubing won't
help a user amass a coherent dream for a
new system because YouTube is always
about to recommend a new radical thinker
with a new were a radical or plan to
influence you as a result you're
investing all this rage without any hope
of return now are we telling you to
never watch an angry youtube video again
of course not but we do think it's
important that everybody recognized the
inherent value of their own rage both as
individuals trying to claim autonomy
over their lives and to online
opportunists who want to turn them into
loyal flat-earthers
remember there is literally a financial
incentive both for YouTube and for
individual creators to keep you angry
and we're no exception which is why I'm
taking this moment to inform you that
clever crevice doesn't think Nicholas
Cage deserved an Oscar but seriously
what do you guys think is raging on the
Internet emotionally healthy totally
toxic or just a harmless indulgence we
all deserve from time to time is the
YouTube algorithm making your rage
impotent and if so how do you feel about
it let us know in the comments thanks to
all our patrons who support the
and our podcasts don't forget to hit
that subscribe button but before you go
I want to give another shout-out to
upstart unlike other loan providers
upstart rewards you based on your
education and job history in the form of
a smarter interest rate check out why
upstart is ranked number one in their
category over 300 businesses on
Trustpilot go to upstart comm slash
wisecrack to find out how low your
upstart rate is today checking your rate
only takes a few minutes and it won't
affect your credit and as always thanks
for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]